everybody welcome back to my youtube
channel it's Olivia Jade more bad news
for Olivia Jade in the wake of the
college admissions scandal only this
time it's not about her college
application it's about her trademark
application all these crazy things that
you don't want to know et has the docs
from the US Patent and Trademark Office
which claim Olivia tried trademarking
two things her name and Olivia Jade
Beauty but they were both rejected why
well according to the docs
Olivia's application was too vague and
had poor punctuation the docs state that
Olivia needs to be more detailed with
her requests quote the nature of
moisturiser and concealer must be
further specified they're also asking
that Olivia clean up her punctuation
quote commas semicolons and apostrophes
are the only punctuation that should be
used in an identification of goods
and/or services so that's what's going
on as for what's next well according to
the docs
olivia has six months to make the
changes or else she'll have to forfeit
her application will you be attending
college and if not what's the next step
on your career you wish to focus on so
I'm doing both I'm gonna be attending
college the trademark mishap comes two
weeks after Olivia's parents Lori
Lachlan and Massimo gia newly were
arrested for their alleged involvement
in paying big money to get Olivia and
her sister Bella into USC a lot has been
going on in life I'm literally moving
into college today specifically the
court Doc's allege that the couple paid
five hundred thousand dollars to have
their daughters designated as recruits
to the school's crew team since then
Lori was dropped by the Hallmark Channel
and Olivia lost sponsorships with
Tresemme and Sephora
I don't know how much of school I'm
gonna attend but I'm gonna go in and
talk to my Dean's and everyone and hope
that I can try and balance at all
you